hey everyone we are back here on
GameSpot's III stage I'm your host Mike
McCarty here with Justin hey Walt how's
it going and we've got a couple members
of Naughty Dog here to talk about
Uncharted lost like Lost Legacy Shauna
Skye creative director and Curt Marga
now the game director thanks so much for
coming on the show today guys
thanks for having us I appreciate it so
a big deal sony at the press conference
opened up with the Lost Legacy and of
course we know the game is coming out
soon but you know standalone title with
a Chloe Frazier and Nadine Ross what is
it like to be kind of back in the
Uncharted series after four closed out
Nathan Drake story well when we when we
did wrap uncharted 4 we felt like we
closed that chapter we're exploring
different story lines in that world we
went through quite a bit pretty in-depth
explorations on it and the Chloe Fraser
Nadine Ross story just kept popping back
out just kept grabbing our attention so
we're pretty excited to engage and get
in close story yeah
Chloe was always a character that we
loved and we kept coming back we you
know explored Sam and Sully and all
these like side characters and Chloe's
the one that we always put a smile on
her face to think about her having her
own game and then the foil to her you
know personality of Nadine who is this
militaristic you know she's a logical
person and Chloe is this kind of more
improvisational that the way that they
see things putting them together got us
excited for what conflicts and you know
how they can handle situations yeah I
was interesting to see during the reveal
last year you know Chloe's kind of like
the classic uncharted to that part of
the era and then Nadine was introduced
and I'm among thieves and everything and
we're sorry a thief sin I mistake uh and
you know like it's kind of cool is like
you see it as kind of marrying the past
and more recent past of Uncharted yeah
it's it's a bit of that it's also the
perfect brew for conflict yeah right I
mean like Kurt was saying we have the
enigmatic thieving hustler Chloe Fraser
and
turn her up with the pragmatic you know
militant extra line leader nadine ross
so yeah it's it's a bit of exploring
that turmoil
yeah it's combining old and new and and
also nadine who was a bad guy in the
last game how she's on our side so yeah
exactly that goes yes in some ways it's
also kind of breaking down that gender
barrier that this is definitely a type
of game uncharted has always had that
great nathan drake male lead in this
you're not only taking one female lead
you have two female leads but like what
was the thinking behind that i mean we
don't we come we approach it as
everything we do in AI dog by what are
the characters were they like how are
these relationships going to grow and
evolve and how will these characters
play off each other so we had these two
great characters and have a new female
and you know there's nothing there's no
barriers to for us like saying yes or no
we're going to choose them one way or
the other it's just these are the two
best characters that we thought would
fit into a story together
yeah i couldn't say it better how the
idea for this kind of stand-alone story
with these two characters come about in
its inception right like at what point
in the original uncharted the four games
did someone say maybe we could do this
to explore chloe further or maybe like
Nadine time the thief's end wasn't
enough to really flesh this out was
there did like someone come down and say
we need to do this because this would be
an awesome side chapter that we could
release I know the process happened
pretty organically you know we like we
said explored a bunch of different
storyline after uncharted 4 so it was
cool we were done with uncharted 4 and
we was sat down to think about what else
could we do and yeah and you know we
started exploring like because this this
is a thieving world it's got a great
cast of characters to pull from Chloe
Fraser was a fan favorite and then
Nadine was paired because she would you
know create the most conflict yeah and
it's kind of the theme of this game is
that you know progress comes through
conflict so it's it's what we were
aiming for yeah I was interesting
playing uncharted 4 because you know
like her Nadine's allegiances are kind
of in questioned throughout the game and
then I'm
spoil anything but you know you get to
the end and I did find myself wanting to
know more about where she came from
because of where she ended up at the end
of a thief's end and you know like her
motivations the whole time are kind of
in question they seem clear-cut at first
and you know she's this really badass
character but then by the end it's very
much I'm not sure I saw everything going
on is there an effort to kind of like
flesh things out and maybe lead that up
to maybe like more answers or just more
like exploring these characters yeah I
think it's it's a general exploration of
these characters right there you know
set out after the tusks of Ganesh as you
know if you saw the trailer you know
they have to navigate the the wild
Western Ghats with these like monumental
two sized you know archaeological ruins
but you know and with this this really
formidable villain after them all right
but most importantly they have to
navigate each other and survive each
other if they're supposed to get this
treasure it's funny you mentioned you
know Nadine at the end of uncharted 4 or
you know she's the self preservationist
instinct is something that they share so
obviously there's conflict but there's
also commonalities between them and
another reason for them to team up and
thinking about this from a developmental
standpoint it seems like an interesting
choice that you said you started on this
well after you've finished uncharted 4
but this is also a standalone thing so I
guess from a developmental standpoint
did you guys ever think about making
this like its own standalone completely
different game why is this DLC but
that's also kind of separate like the
last of a left behind for the last us so
it kind of it is its own game it's it
grew it in true nigh dog fashion uh you
know we just do like the biggest version
of everything we can possibly imagine
but it yeah it it just we learned that
to have these characters have the arcs
that they want to have and for the
relationships to grow and change we
really needed the space to to build that
out so it it became a full game yeah I
mean that Naughty Dog we you know kind
of pride ourselves you know telling
stories about the human condition
and in deep story arcs and character
character arcs so just by the nature of
that you know what started as a smaller
project just expanded into this full
game you know you're looking at Naughty
Dog's games you see you know obviously
you start off with like going way back
you start off with crash and then you
come to like Jack and Dexter and then
you come to Uncharted and then the last
of us it looks like it gets
progressively more mature and more
serious or more maybe a little more
melancholic or just dark in general and
then you see the Lost Legacy the reveal
and then you see it this year and it
looks like it's even like darker than a
thief's end which I think was a bit like
one of the more mature Uncharted games
is there an effort to make this game
maybe a little bit more ominous in tone
I think by the nature of the character
her selves or the character themselves
so Chloe and Nadine the tone has shifted
I don't think there was a intent to make
it more you know dark or anything that's
still the action-packed adventure in
fact there's a lot of the Uncharted
world that we kind of harnessed or
brought back almost like a some of the
in charted worlds so big adventure high
combat or intense combat and Chloe's a
exploration it was a fun character for
sure yeah and there she's definitely fun
in this game yeah she led to a lot of
like comic relief with her and her
relationship with Drake and even Elena
and I tried it - yeah there's definitely
some callbacks to previous games that
people enjoy is this primarily built on
the the previous game and just kind of
an addition of story are you changing
any of the mechanics or is there any
good any additions like that uh you know
when we thought about this game and you
know who Chloe is and as a character and
then mechanically how we wanted to
expand uncharted you know we went to
Chloe's a kind of you know she's the
schemer is the line and the trailer says
so you know we have the lock-picking
mechanic of and we showed that PSX which
is a game line thing we can use it to
unlock things we have other weapons and
things you can find in treasures there's
also just a push for more player choice
in general there were doing bigger
spaces and more exploration and
there's stealth options we can have
silenced weapons and things so there's a
lot more of just player choice in
general also we've kind of spilled in
our narrative into gameplay a little
more you know if the characters arcs are
in a certain space then their
relationship as you play with them is
also change or affected by that
characterize it thinking about those
experiments that you you get to make
especially with a company as
technological as Sony behind you guys
did you think about doing anything with
PlayStation VR you know we've seen a lot
of companies not use that to make full
games but to add on experiences like
that is that something you toyed around
with or thought about for this I mean we
love the psvr PSP are super awesome I
have one at home there's some great
games on there I mean for us in the kind
of story want to tell the platform you
know we're just we're focused on you
know what we we do well the console game
VR is a exciting for us to play but you
know maybe in the future doesn't mean we
won't explore it
yeah it's interesting I must I imagine
must have been kind of thrilling but
nerve-wracking to like have this you
know this beloved franchise one of like
the most beloved videogames and then say
we're gonna tell another story outside
of the traditional arc of Nathan Drake
can you talk about like what was going
through your head when you first sat
down to get to work on this project I
mean we just I mean I think the team
really embraced this project from the
get-go when we started once we locked on
the actual story everyone was excited
about Chloe and what Chloe would do in
such situations like how would you know
this thieving hustler double dealing
character you know pair up with yet the
pragmatic Nadine as they search for this
tusk the stable treasure from the
Haskalah people and then having a very
formidable very intelligent and low-key
character or villain character be after
them someone who's you know got ties or
thinks he's got ties to this land so you
know the whole premise of the story was
pretty exciting so I don't think we
approach it as nerve-wracking we were
just so pumped we got jumped in head
kind of a relief in a way that uncharted
was over because we knew ok those
characters are off limits we want that
right that ending to be meaningful so
completely off limits was Nathan Drake
and those characters and it's kind of a
blank slate in some ways where we can
take these characters that are
lesser-known
and build our own arcs and our own
backstories and things so it's been
exciting in that way for sure did it
feel limiting in at all thinking about
coming at this from a digital
perspective that this isn't a full
retail game so you can't just go crazy
and make this 60 hours long you do have
some limits right um I don't know if we
receptive there I guess there's a limit
somewhere but I mean we we built this
story and we tried to you know we're
just trying to tell the story and the
game turned out being a lot bigger than
we had initially thought and it turned
into a you know a full game so if
there's limits I guess we haven't really
seen them yet we're always pushing all
of me that's not sure that's the one
thing we do well cool uh yeah just one
last question I guess when can we play
this soon right yeah
August 22nd second cool so its 22nd all
right Sean and Kurt thanks so much for
coming on thanks for having X guys if
you're watching this from home we will
be having more game demos more developer
interviews here from our e3 stage
throughout the week so stay tuned the
game spot we'll see you around